because I I would like like obviously a
lot of this stuff is highly back to the
camera phones thing we see a lot more of
the people getting robbed on Sunset or
on Melrose and it's like yeah that kind
of [__] has always been happening in LA
but I feel like back in the day it was
really like Peak you kind of had to come
to LA and like
if you were gonna move around you really
had to be in line with some guys to make
sure that there wasn't any sort of yeah
yeah that was the whole like uh the tap
in Era the tap in Era people's chains
were getting took people had to get the
chains yeah you get the chain back we
got it I mean you know I got a couple
chains back from some for some uh some
rappers actually no basketball players
whose chain did you get
hey bro we don't talk like that what
label were they from I don't even know
what label I just know they're one of my
favorite you know one of my favorites uh
you know a couple rappers man just
that's just how I be you know what I
mean like a couple rappers just like
and you got to think like coming up in
that game area with the game when gang
was first starting to like break out
like it was no blood rappers
it wasn't no Bloods famous period you
know what I mean yeah if you really
think outside of Mack 10 yeah it was Mac
10 and then and then the game and then
everybody was a blood everybody started
being Bloods you know what I mean so
imagine like
rocking with the blood that is on this
on his way up you know what I mean in
L.A so it was a lot to deal with with
that and he was the face of La for like
a decade yeah he had carried the whole
coach for like a very long time yeah and
and I think it just kind of for me like
hanging with game
made me realize that okay man my plan
was me and gang rocking together I mean
he can unify the music I can unify the
hoop and then we can create this
La unified system where like we can make
it better for dudes right you know what
I mean like we can stop
all the jacking and [__] like that you
know what I'm saying like at least if
they [__] with us right rolling with
us you're not gonna get checked you
ain't gonna get robbed you ain't gonna
get into no funny business you know what
I mean and like that was the goal is
really like once I saw that I was like
man like nip coming Don I'm coming you
know YG I'd had a couple songs but YG
was on his way you know what I mean it
was a bunch of dudes just like on a rise
and I was like damn dude uh Kendrick you
know what I mean Jay Rock was out but
Jay Rock was like on his way so like uh
I remember we did the gang the Crips and
bloods gang documentary and uh I was
like man I need to put a soundtrack
together
and on the soundtrack is all them dudes
like damn their first soundtrack right I
remember how long ago was that
documentary uh I think I want to say 20
2015. no 204 I think 2004. yeah Jesus
Christ yeah it was like 2004 or when I
got to
it was like 2004. I think I was in New
Orleans when I came out when you end up
on the Clippers
being a guy who's from where you're from
playing in La obviously not for the
Lakers but play for the Clippers for
sure you guys had a very very
entertaining team
um but was it like how much of the like
extra [__] did you have to deal with
being home
all of it uh you know what like Ben
playing for the Clippers like and I
never really talk about that [__]
because people always talk about don't
leave here Donald Sterling right you
know what I mean but just playing for
the Clippers like my mission when I left
golden state was like all right I know
the Clippers are the Clippers right
coming back home to hopefully do what I
did in Golden State I told Golden State
give me three years you know what I mean
would be in the playoffs if we get the
right people around you know what I mean
like that's what I like that's what I
wanted to do so coming here it was like
yeah if I can get the Clippers to the
playoffs if I can turn the Clippers
around then it'll be a whole different
story you know what I mean so historical
at that point it would have been
historical
um and so like that was kind of like my
mission it was like I need to get
through those first three years
because the first three years is all
[__] you know what I mean you gotta
clean up you know all just negative [__]
that be going around and you got to
protect your teammates and then you got
to build your teammates to where they
feel like they can walk in like we
walking in the season and like it's just
us you know what I mean and then it's us
and the coaches and then everybody else
it's our family you know what I mean and
I think with the Clippers it was just
that [__] was just hard bro that's it
was just hard because it was a lot of
racism sexism uh backstabbing people
telling lies snitching and [__] I was
like man I thought we came to work to
play basketball